the U.S is defending its decision to
deliver the widely banned controversial
cluster Munitions to Ukraine the move to
send the weapons which can harm
civilians even decades after the bombs
drop as Congress and the world split
ahead of the NATO Summit in Lithuania
next week some like Democratic
representative Chrissy Houlihan and
human rights groups say it's blurring
the lines of moral ground but Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski thanked
President Biden and said that this will
bring Kiev closer to Victory more than
16 months after Russia's Invasion
Charlie dagada reports now from Ukraine
terrifying lethal and highly effective
Ukraine is no stranger to cluster bombs
both sides have been accused of
deploying them since Russia launched its
Invasion with devastating effect it's a
weapon that breaks up mid-air as it
approaches its Target ejecting a number
of smaller explosives or bomblets
scattering indiscriminately across an
area that constructs to the size of
several football fields most of those
explosives detonate but not all posing a
threat to the civilian population long
after the war has ended especially
children
here in hartkeve investigators have
built a mountain of Russian Munitions
and evidence of their use in civilian
areas these are just some of the Russian
cluster bombs that have been recovered
here in the Harkey region and this is an
example of a detonated bomblet which
would have been packed with explosives
Ukraine says it needs the help in a
stalled counter-offensive against
entrenched Russian troops backing the
White House's argument that the use of
the controversial weapons is on
Ukraine's watch
Ukraine would not be using these
Munitions in some foreign land this is
their country they're defending these
are their citizens they're protecting
for CBS Saturday morning Charlie dagada
our key Ukraine